- Know this, I'm
the most moldable.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- The one thing I don't want
to do is say something I don't
believe in 'cause that will
undermine everything I got.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this was the
last Monday
morning of your life?
("Silence" by Madreal)
- [Gary] Strategy, insights,
data and creative teams and
that (censored) thousand pays
for all the creative output.
That's right, you know it's
interesting, there's actually
two people I'm think
about right now that
I'm about to allocate
to something else.
Probably take this off.
So, DRock, you're
extremely stressed today--
- [DRock] Not really.
- [Gary] Yes, you are.
You've already been antsy.
Now you're asking me
to make this film.
Mads, don't you think
he's super stressed?
- [Madelina] No.
He looks good.
- He looks good.
Looking good and being stressed,
you're worried that we're not
going to be able to make a
really strong episode today.--
- [DRock] Not at all.
Not at all.
- because I'm filming
"Planet of the Apps" and
they're not letting
you do anything.
- [DRock] A little bit.
- So, all you got is Wendy
doing my make-up, right?
- [DRock] Yep.
- And, maybe Madelina
running around and organizing.
- [DRock] Yep.
- And so, you're worried.
Admit that you're
worried about today.
- [DRock] I'm a little worried.
- [Gary] I knew it, I know you.
(group laughter)
My only favorite move
is what I'm about
to do right now which is talk to
the Vayner Nation and tell them
listen, I'm sorry that the
episode, what is this,
episode 104? Or 105?
- [DRock] 104.
- 104, I'm sorry that DRock
thinks that episode 104
is gonna suck but it's not.
Giving away something to
the 60 Second Club giveaways.
So we're about to
give Marshall Paul Live
three minutes of my time.
I saw that he saw it.
This is my favorite
Snapchat feature right here.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Yo, you there?
He's there.
Alright.
(phone chimes)
Here we go.
Yo!
- [Marshall] Going
live with GaryVee.
- [Gary] You are
very live with GaryVee.
How are you?
- [Marshall] Heck yeah, man.
What's going on Gary?
- [Gary] Good man.
What's going on with you?
- [Marshall] Thank you
so much for taking time
out of your day to do this.
- [Gary] No problem.
- [Marshall] I've been consuming
everything that
you put out, man.
You're making me a better me.
- [Gary] I love that, man.
Thank you so much.
So, we got 180 seconds.
What's the best
thing I can give you?
- [Marshall] Okay, the best
thing you can give me,
my friend, I'm just starting
off as an entrepreneur.
I just started my own
social media marketing agency--
- [Gary] Okay.
- my question I have for you is
if you were going back to the
very beginning and you
were starting from nothing,
like I am. No money,--
- [Gary] Right.
- you're always
talking about momentum.
You always talk about
keeping the momentum going,
keep the momentum going.
When you're in a lull and that
momentum seems to stop,
how can I keep the momentum
going in my life,
in my business?
- [Gary] So is it, when time are
tough you're getting to a place
where, it's just hard to
quote-unquote get
up in the morning.
Just trying to breakthrough
the adversity that is
naturally always there?
- [Marshall] You know the
adversity is always gonna be
there to some point.
I don't usually have
problems with that.
It's just like today for
example, you know,
I got a shoutout from
(censored) last night.
I get this three minute
conversation with you and this
is a perfect example of when
momentum is really
rocking and rolling.
- [Gary] Yep.
- [Marshall] How can I
capitalize on that and continue
that momentum when that
momentum is ready to stop.
How do you personally
keep that momentum going?
- [Gary] By recognizing how
insignificant and significant
these things are.
So this three minutes together
is amazing and it's awesome and
you won this time,
you hustled for it but you know
this three minutes
with you and I
is not going to be the reason that
you're successful in business.
It's a nice to have.
I think too many people over,
people always think like okay
now that this happened, this is
the reason I'm gonna blow up.
How old are you?
- [Marshall] 32.
- Good. Nothing good is gonna
happen for the next 10 years.
- [Marshall] I'm okay with that.
- But honestly, if you actually
believe that versus just saying
that to me 'cause you know
I care about that then you don't
need anything else from me.
Do you understand?
- [Marshall] Right,
I do, absolutely.
- That's it, man.
When it's, when you're down
realize how amazing it is and
when you're up realize how
not great it's gonna be. Right?
It's pushing the opposite
direction of what it looks like
actually is happening.
- [Marshall] I love it.
- Got it?
- [Marshall] I have one
last question for you.
- Yep. Yep.
- [Marshall] What do you think
Jay Cutler for Bryce Petty,
would you do it?
- No. I don't
any old quarterback
as much as I have no idea if
Bryce Petty's gonna work
out I know it is in Romo.
I have no
interest in Kaepernick.
I have no interest in Cutler.
I want to go young.
I want to be
crap for five years,
rebuild and then make a run.
Patience.
- [Marshall] Gary,
I love consuming
everything you put out, man.
- Thank you.
- [Marshall] Thank you so much
for taking time out of your day.
I love it.
- Thanks, brother.
Take care, bye-bye.
Awesome.
Access. That's--
- [Tyler] That was good.
- Access is, right,
that's so amazing.
First of all, that's triple
win because he's pumped.
We just created good content.
I don't know if I remember
saying when it's one way push
the other way, that's
what I actually do.
- Right.
- That's balance.
Never let it, when
it's a high, go low.
When it's low, go high.
And he wins, now the community's
getting a lot more access,
the whole thing's fricking great.
("Silence" by Madreal)
- Know this, I'm
the most moldable.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- The one thing I don't want
to do is say something I don't
believe in 'cause that will
undermine everything I got.
Happy, DRock?
- [DRock] Very happy.
- [Gary] Yo, my man. Cool.
- What's going on, my brother?
- [Ne-Yo] What's
going on, my man?
- [Phil] Nice to meet you.
- [DRock] Hey man. How are you?
- Good to see you, my man.
- [Ne-Yo] Good to see you too.
- Great to see you.
- Everything all good?
- Really good.
Swipe up. Looking pretty.
Swipe up, swipe up.
- [Man 2] Swipe up.
- [Gary] Swipe up.
What's crazy is this quote came
because he's filming me all day,
we make a show and then we pull
shit, the amount of smart and
creative shit that must be
coming out of your dome.
- Mhmmm.
- Just knowing you
from afar, magic.
But it's just lost in history.
- Yeah.
- If I told you, Ne-Yo, the
celebrity, looking, going to
five Targets and trying
to find a Christmas tree.
'Cause you know.
You don't even understand.
The thing that people don't
understand is people can sit and
make fun of the Kardashians or
DJ Khaled, things like that.
There's so much, it all
goes back to reality TV.
People are just intrigued.
- [Ne-Yo] Mhmmm.
- Yeah.
- You know what's even
better than TV though.
We edit.
- [Ne-Yo] Hmmm.
- Yeah, you sign with Discovery
Channel or you sign with MTV or
you sign with Fox
you don't get to say.
They'll put you in
the, that's right.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] When you have your
DRock and one other person and
you're sitting there and at the
end and you're watching for
20 minutes and be like,
"Oh, shit, I said that thing.
I can't let Karen know that."
I do it all day.
I never watch any of my own
shit, now I have to because
there might be some little
subtle thing I say that I know
that employee if they watch
it that means they're getting
fired, I got to kill it.
- [Man 2] Of course.
- I kinda had this concern
about giving away something.
- [Gary] That game's over.
- I'm not that way.
- [Gary] By the way,--
- I just feel like--
- [Gary] That game's over.
- to let them hear it
before it's completely complete.
- [Gary] By the way, by the way,
I completely respect that and,
by the way, that's your art.
I don't want to tell you what to
do but here's
what I would tell you.
I assume,
tell me if I'm wrong,
I'm just making
some assumptions,
you're always debating several,
songs don't make the cut.
- [Ne-Yo] Mhmmm.
- [Man 2] Of course.
- So one of the things I think,
and you also probably know when
a song, you know when a song's
like 90%, and you're like
this song's definitely
gonna make it.
I just got to fix
it up a little.
You probably know when songs
are at 10% and may not make it.
- [Ne-Yo] Yeah.
- You can be smart about
what you share and don't share.
You know? If you're like,
"Ah, this is 50-50."
One thing, actually
those are bad examples.
50-50, you're fucking with it.
That would be cool because you
would fuck with it, people would
see it, and then you'd read
the comments and
be like, "Oh, okay."
- [DRock] Yeah.
- I actually think, look,
there's that classic thing where
the guy that invented the
Porche said if I listened to my
audience I would've made a
faster Toyota or some shit.
I don't remember
exactly what he said.
So I don't think your audience
should be making your music.
That's why you're you.
I do think though that once in a
while the feedback isn't too bad
and you can pick
up some nuances.
- You got to pay attention.
Shit don't stay the same.
- [Ne-Yo] Not at all.
- It's the way it
should be, right?
Here's what you've got.
When you have talent,
it doesn't take as much.
Same with me as an entrepreneur,
like I'm actually a
good businessman.
I'm not just
saying it on Instagram.
- Mhmmm.
- [Ne-Yo] Mhmmm.
- You know?
So once you deploy the talent to
the right place where people are
paying attention, it explodes.
So you're in a big,
big, big advantage.
It's just time for you to
reframe the way you
think about the world.
It's just real.
And you're gonna be in a
relationship with your fans.
Go figure.
(group laughter)
Go figure. Got it?
- [Ne-Yo] Got it.
- And the best part, you know,
I'll be real frank with you,
man, you're a good dude.
Like, I've been really kinda
doing my homework a little bit
since we met.
You're gonna win big.
You're just likable.
You're just real likable
and that shit matters.
- Person first.
- [Gary] That's
why you're gonna--
- Your gift and my curse.
- [Gary] 100%, mine too.
But guess what?
Those are the best things.
Cool.
- Thank you, G.
- Great to see you, T.
- Pleasure.
- [Gary] Yeah, always.
- Appreciate it, brother.
- Any time.
Yeah, you guys too.
Let me know how I can help.
I'll wait for you to hit me up.
You guys ponder,
feel what's right, you know?
- [Man 2] Hmm.
- Cool. Alright guys, take care.
- [Ne-Yo] Nice to meet you, bro.
Happy holidays you guys.
- Thank you. Thank you.
- Every time he said
DRock, I said (inaudible).
(group laughter)
- DRockefeller.
Ne-Yo's a good dude.
Whether you're
a super famous artist
or a Joe Schmoe like me,
telling your story, consistently
and authentically in the place
where people pay
attention, that's the game.
Hey, hey.
- What's up?
- [Gary] What's up?
- DRock, how you doing?
- [DRock] Nice to meet you.
- [Tom] I'm Tom. Pleasure.
- [Woman 2] Hi.
Nice to meet you.
- [DRock] Likewise.
- [Tom] So, what's up, dude?
- Things are good, man.
I'm glad we were able
to make this happen.
Sorry I'm a little late.
- [Tom] Don't sweat it.
It's not a big deal.
- You're here, right?
That's right.
- Yeah.
- That's why I asked you.
You live here.
How'd the meeting
go with the team?
- Very well.
- Good.
- I like your team.
They assured me that you're like
the poof of cloud
behind the throne there.
No, they were
amazing man, I loved them.
Had a great time,
super bright, very personable.
- [Gary] Good and they're built
to know what our
issues are which is time.
- [Tom] Yes.
- That's the only
thing that matters.
- [Tom] So true.
- So true, so one, in this time
we have together is there...
I hope they gave you the energy
of what I want everybody to know
which is, it's weird.
What I'm about to say
you're gonna find funny.
I don't like selling.
- [Tom] I don't find that funny.
I watch enough of
your content to--
- Know that?
- [Tom] Yeah.
- So, I don't love B2B.
Like Under Armour and Chase and
Budweiser, I hate this so much.
Selling a person on a
service is even worse.
- [Tom] Right.
- But, what I will say is
I'm proud that, you knowing my
narrative, everybody wanted this
seven years ago and I went and
sold Chase and Pepsi because
I knew I could bring them value
for what they paid me.
It took me and I only unlocked
it, you probably saw the deck
when my numbers exploded--
- [Tom] Yeah.
- only in the last year have
I really, really, figured out
how to make this
worthwhile to you,
to Ne-Yo who
just like, you know.
I figured it out.
We got it.
- [Woman 2] Yeah.
- So now, it's not scary.
- [Tom] Right.
No, I love that and value is the
only thing that's
sustainable so--
- [Gary] The only
thing that's sustainable.
- Yeah.
("Silence" by Madreal)
- But I think CES
is the right time.
- [Tom] Okay.
- Alright?
- Sounds good.
- Great to see you again.
Take care.
Such a pleasure.
Thank you.
- Yeah. Absolutely.
- Take care. It was
real nice meeting you.
Good to see you.
- [Gary] Take care, brother.
Tyler, I got to go.
Hey Andrea.
Just about to go on
a conference call.
Great day.
Film some TV, hung in L.A.,
hung out with some
VaynerTalent meetings.
Living the dream.
Going to work out now.
See you later.